I can't say I felt represented growing
up I think the only Latin character that
there is in the Disney Universe is a
chihuahua I think the Princess and the
Frog I was kind of older so I didn't
really wasn't really able to get into it
I have faith that Disney is gonna get
there one day and I know that you know
if you need a cream male character to
base anything on totally a cartoon
already so if we make you a Korean
Prince then that would be excellent so
I'm on this mission to destroy this Fox
princess this priestess and I'm
accompanied by my dog so my prince is a
merman I want to think he falls in love
with a guy who sings with his batter I
feel like is Maya Angelou and Fran
Lebowitz had a baby that would be me so
I put earrings on you sometimes I wear
them from Claire's wrinkle a lot of swag
swords sword then black powder
yeah he's way cooler than me
pickles my eyes okay I'm scared oh my
god oh my god I love it
that is so cool oh that's dope
oh hell yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I never realized how much I look
like and like a Spanish like Corsa and
there's a little heart on my face looks
perfect hearts me actually my symbol
that I put on everything
I definitely wanna see it as a movie I
got a pitch now I gotta write it I think
for me like when I started growing my
hair out it means a lot it was like oh
this is could be different I need
different reactions from people and I
kind of felt like a strength in it dang
and my eyebrows on fleek - I really love
the Hat I love the details of the the
clothes and I am really just digging my
dog companion who also has a sword I am
the first gay Cuban Merman of Disney
thanks John this is amazing this looks
so good not only Korean kids could
respond this but I think a lot of kids
in general would respond to this you
could really base an animated film off
of any one story or anyone's dream and
it can come up into something awesome
and marketable and I think this looks
like both